hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
the Domino level with you I don't have
any other scares to give you I've been
trying to do it but sometimes things
just gotta go you can't repeat the same
thing over and over again every video
and expected it's still stay fresh
that's just unrealistic sometimes you
just gotta believe new opportunities are
putting up every door new things at any
moment new opportunities new spooks new
scares sometimes the most surprising
things hit you in the most unsurprising
waters so without further ado we're
going to go with this game unthread how
to play move interact Crouch his space
grab look around I like the visual of
the melting man oh I hate it already
wait I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry wait a
minute that's the wait a minute are you
telling me that I'm one of these things
and I just popped myself right off of a
hook oh that's what you're telling me
isn't it oh that is exactly what you're
telling me
oh I hate that oh it's just pieces it's
just pieces that's been stitched
together
oh that's ah what can be open with this
crew draft wait are those footsteps
actually something I should worry about
probably hammer
are you trying to tell me that there's
something there that's gonna get me Oh
Oh gramma grama ball hi
don't mind me just one of your flesh
puppets springing to life I hate that I
don't like that at all
I'm gonna wait for granny to go by if
that is granny
maybe it's mother mother
oh hi you know what actually I've
discovered I don't really care but that
does look like a granny shuffle
oh no that's a mother No mother mother
okay
oh that's a handy hole I got a hurry or
else I'm gonna get caught nail in the
open with my pants down I need a
screwdriver I think Oh school she can
hear you no she's coming this way or not
she's off to the that way okay I think
she's going farther away okay okay this
is like granny
this really is okay so I still need to
find some kind of a screwdriver probably
um can I open this no damn it oh [ __ ]
that's not good oh that's not good okay
okay there was a hole here I don't know
if it's a good idea to go in the hole
but I'm going in the hole for some
reason that was noisy but I'm somewhere
oh I can't read that what am I looking
for I do not know what I'm looking for
okay so it's moderately unsettling but I
think that I'm relatively okay I never
mind everybody who ever oh my god I
didn't know that you could run later oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh go go go go go okay um we're
just gonna pretend like that never
happened I don't know why I felt safe I
don't have a I don't have a I am high up
I'm flying
there's a hammer here but I can't get
the hammer I don't know I don't know
this game is weird so I need a
screwdriver but what did I even need the
screwdriver for I've completely
forgotten oh you have the electrical box
that's what it was so that was a bit of
a bust
good news is I am faster than grandma
that is some good news so long as I can
stay mobile I should be fine so I just
got to find a screwdriver then be out of
here
wherever screwdriver might be what is
that candle oh right click right click
is pick up that would be very helpful to
know grab that means I can go get the
hammer in them whatever I needed the
hammer for I can use the hammer on no oh
god no
my ankles Graham Mimi grammy-maw my
ankles you got me okay fine men if
you're gonna be like that grandma MA I
ain't gonna play nice either think I'm
gonna play nice no I'm not at least the
hammer is in the same place she's at
comon
can I just like bash her ankle with this
hammer and then be done with her right
also why does she got a flesh face - oh
God oh ye gods
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine open open open open is there
anything in here I have no idea Oh God
turns a see get open the doors pretty
quick turns up surprisingly pretty quick
pretty quick on the doors okay we're
fine I think if we just make our way
through here and then get to the next
area we'll be fine okay so she's got it
all it's toys broken find a handle to
fix it Wow the toy is broken why do I
need to fix the toy I don't know I don't
know anything there's probably something
in the umpteen bajillion drawers that
were over there crowbar a hammer what
was that that's a knife no give give
give give give give give give it give it
I see it Oh God is that the store
screwdriver granite oh my god there we
go
Go Go the closet oh my god I found the
screw they're just gonna wait for her to
come this way go beyond do whatever this
screwdriver does I don't know I don't
know how long this game is either
because it seems like a lot of steps
that I gotta take care of and I don't
even know if I'm gonna be able to do
them all wait no no wait no wait what no
no no no no you shuffling lady no way no
way no no no yeah you squat down there
you squat down there I got a do a thing
or two oh I got a do a thing or two I
got a float down gently like a butterfly
go over here do whatever this do okay
got it
what is oh the handle that's important I
know
the handle goes handle goes on the toy
everyone knows the who's the boy I just
gotta get in the hole and then I gotta
keep moving
cuz once I'm in the hole I'm scot-free
cuz I know the toys on the other side
and then whatever the toy does which I
don't know of what it would do besides
be like a jack-in-the-box or something
but it'll give me something and then
I'll be able to get something else and
then I'll be able to move on then I'm
able to get out of here I see how this
goes something nice
what am I gonna stab her I don't know
what to do with the knife what would I
do with the knife something in the
bathroom maybe wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
lady lady lady lady oh do something I
was safe oh that made my toes curl
what'd you do that to me I thought it
was safe what the hell what the hell all
right you know what I'm not playin
around lady anymore good god that
actually started oh god damn it are you
kidding me I don't know what to do with
the knife
how can you suck yeah that's what you do
you suck
yeah you suck can I even go around you
all I can
yeah oh I'm too fast for you okay so
you're not even a threat I can just
scoot around you scoot around you have
full speed no consequences easy peasy
okay so knife what would I do with a
knife besides the obvious of stabbing
her which I don't think is an option
she's got to be something else that I
can stab maybe one of the meat puppets
maybe that's what I need to steer maybe
one of the meat puppets needs to get
stabbed so I can get something out of
the meat what do I do with the knife all
right
lost now I think I've gone to all the
areas that I need to go to
so where would I bring the knife oh hey
all right lady we're gonna do this we're
gonna dance this dance I can get pretty
close okay so this spook factor has been
eliminated a little bit which is fine I
gotta figure out where to put this knife
if I can't put it in the back of her
skull oh well well well looks like we
got ourselves a crew bur I'll take that
you want to get warm Flay
it's soaked Rover Kroeber open ah
interesting
tur let's turn anything in the air
that's interesting and necessary for me
maybe I should go get the knife I'll
come get it when I need you all right Oh
a back way into here but that doesn't
help me wait what's that but can't
another candle how many candles do I
need I don't know where where what do
the candles go Oh pincer
okay pincer I know that was needed for
the chains right here
yes pincer open got it okay another
candle that's good anything else be a ye
a ye come on Lady
I've actually got something to lose now
will you dare don't you keep moving lady
okay so candle is that it's just another
candle I don't even know what the
candles are for I don't see anything
else unless I need to knife that guy
which is possible it's leaving the
candles there for now where did I put
that knife back in the schoolroom oh
[ __ ] Oh God egads okay that's that
gadzooks on that one
okay I'm gonna go in here I'm gonna get
the knife I'm gonna assume that maybe I
need to stab somebody
can I please could I please could I be
as evident thank you oh wait what do I
need for this
this not even a door I could go through
probably not there's another candle [ __ ]
can she hear that oh she can hear that
okay yeah she can hear that she can hear
that all right she can really hear that
anything else in here nah just that god
damn it what else do I need
that's right move on back okay so I've
got there's a bunch of candles I don't
know what the candles are for I don't
know if I'm supposed to bring the
candles back I don't know if I have a
way to light the candles I don't know
where the candles are supposed to go I
don't know where the knife is for I've
kind of had kind of a dead end here like
what else could I possibly do with all
this stuff maybe this is all about the
candles and I got to bring the candles
back oh god man I hate it when this
happens like a game is too obscure where
I don't know what I'm doing and I don't
know why I'm doing it I'm all about
mystery but I'm not so much about
aimless wandering eye and that's all it
feels like I'm doing I'm wandering
aimlessly the enemy has no longer become
a threat so I'm not as spooked therefore
all the contrivances that are supposed
to lead me on through the game are kind
of just acting as a hindrance instead of
being motivational you know what I mean
cuz I don't know if I'm running away
from this lady I don't know why I'm
running away from this lady I don't know
what I'm trying to do is it revenge like
is that what I'm trying to do am I
trying to accomplish some kind of like
way to get my other flesh puppet
brethren alive again say I really don't
know and that's kind of kind of sucks
because this this gave me it's got a lot
of potential I love the styling of it
but at the same time I can't get into it
if it won't give me anything and now
I've reached this stopping point where
I'm just gonna try to stab this lady you
come here yeah
hi and then especially if I'd like get a
game over and I have to reset all of
that progress and go through the whole
problem I'm trying to do this again man
that sucks oh well hey and unfortunately
I just don't have the time to finish it
right now I I don't honestly truly do
not have the time to see this to its
completion I don't even know if I was
close to the end or if there was a whole
other phase waiting for me unfortunately
right now I have to let this one live
but if you guys want to play for
yourself and see the end of it there is
a link in the description right down
there click read more and you will find
this game where you can play it for
yourself
for now though sometimes the most
surprising things this is crunchy a
horror game based off of Captain Crunch
scour the island for boxes of Captain
Crunch cereal you may find them inside
various landmarks crunchy will patrol
the island in search of trespassers such
as yourself he said the only enemy
capable of killing you Crunchy's pals
want in on the fun
each one is capable of ruining your run
okay easy it's early in the morning
crunchy traps some locations crunchy
moves a regular speed crunching will
investigate some noises cereal boxes
have static spawns the classic nighttime
experience trapped locations regular
speed investigating noises slightly
random spawns crunchy trapped the whole
damn island crunchy moves faster than
you will investigate thoroughly boxes
are scattered around the fog is thicker
Seymour wants you dead whose seaboard
give me the [ __ ] hard one I'm going
going Jim here's the deal don't argue
with me alright I got a lot of money
going on this job life is hard we lost
our goddamn prized
boxes of Captain Crunch cereal and don't
you dare look at them funny alright you
hear me or else I'm gonna blow up your
house not not really I'll just extra dog
for my paycheck because you know we're
kind of low on funds but grab those
boxes should I look around and bring
them back to me personally oh yeah I
don't let him see you you might love
reading on who he is
good luck employee wait
Oh stupid [ __ ] okay find all eight
boxes of Captain Crunch cereal here we
go baby
we're doing this hard mode because I
hate myself all right I have no idea
what this island is gonna be like I'm on
a bit of a time crunch today so I don't
even know if I'm gonna be able to beat
this either but uh here we go
maybe I should have done this on like a
normal difficulty or something maybe
doing this immediately at Hard
difficulty is a terrible idea maybe this
is like the worst thing to do maybe I
should go back and do normal maybe what
I what when I die I'll probably end up
doing that don't get me wrong I love
Captain Crunch I do is one of my
favorite cereals I mean it's terrible
for you
it's got like no nutritional value it's
just pure sugar but hey isn't that what
we all grew up on and we turned out okay
which are not fine hello if there's
nothing oh yes there is
oh yeah baby yeah baby
screw my boss I'm gonna shove those
right in my job all right if that was a
landmark what the hell oh no no no no no
no no the captain's coming captain's mad
oh hello aha Oh scary well
now that we got that out of the way I
will never be scared again because it
was a cheap jump scare and it shouldn't
have got me in the first place therefore
it was not worthy of my fear and when I
conquer my fear nothing shall stand in
my way I've got a exceptionally runny
nose today and I don't know why okay
what do we have here this looks like a
thing me captain crow I probably
shouldn't crunch on those sticks
okay yeah I said you were not worthy of
my fear so get the hell out of here
before I shove my foot up your rear oh
you are faster than me hey that's not
fair that's not bad alright so obviously
that difficulties a little too much I'm
going to Normal difficulty oh maybe if I
turn it off turn off my flashlight give
me that give me that give me that
keep it up oh that's probably not a good
idea Crouch my lights off you can't find
me that's how this works it's law even
you captain after you obey the law you
think there's Captain Crunch fanfiction
I mean is Captain Crunch game now so
maybe there's got to be like a good
fanfiction I'm four of eight baby I'm
gonna kick your ass no no
no no you don't know where I am anymore
does it turn my light off and therefore
that's the only mechanism with which to
disappear
it is what is fair oh [ __ ]
oh god but how will I ever survive
you'll never get my boxes opted crunch
can you come up here tell me you can't
come up here all right bet you can't I
bet you can't I'm lean and lead or are
you waiting at the bottom of the ladder
for me to fall down
oh he's not there I'm out of here I was
a bird while I was there scared of a
bird who cares about a bird a bird get
out of your bird know what squawking -
nothing that's pretty interesting okay
alright that's pretty intricate
interactions between the different
forces that are be set against me
also what's at the top of this what is
that what is it oh is birds okay whose
boards
hey there's box I see it yum yum yum yum
give me the box
he's six of am kicking your ass captain
stealing all your goodies and you don't
even know all right so I've ran the
circumference of the island and I'm 6 of
8 so I'm pretty sure that I've got a
start moving inland at some point unless
I don't and then that's good too
thankfully the boxes do kind of glow in
the dark ooh what is that what was that
captain listen I'm just here to steal
some crunch berries and then I'm gonna
get out and then I go home and then I
leave okay I definitely think I got to
start moving inland wait a minute
everybody hold on to your horses we've
got a pirate ship to explore Oh God ask
her
screw it got to go God do it one more to
go one more just one more
oh yeah oh yeah baby Oh God he comes
come get some crunchy boy no oh god he's
coming after me why would he come after
me no no no no listen you can't see me
I'm breaking the line of sight I'm
breaking line of sight I'm breaking line
of me please leave me alone is there any
way to get away from me I don't know how
to do it how do I do it how do I get
away from you if I can't possibly run
away then what can I possibly do to get
away from you oh god Lisa's not faster
than me we're gonna do yeah where did I
go where did I go you don't know where I
want you don't know where where'd you go
boy what is this Oh what is this no no
I'm not here that's what I thought
please be in here please please please
oh come on ding dong meat ooh I'll have
the crunch King eat my ass captain I did
it but what made those boxes of Captain
Crunch so special no I guess I never
will thank you seeing deke cardboard
games
Oh Dave microwave - yeah good stuff
thank you alright
that was very good surprisingly
well-made fluid experience kind of
spooky but silly moving on this one is
called no connections allowed if you
remember again called no players online
this one is similar huh weird doesn't
seem to be anyone online now maybe just
needs to get the party started maybe
I'll jump in this server and maybe we'll
get a good time going
this is my favorite game after all ooh
that's interesting that's not what I
expected hello how are you I asked you
first
oh that's really mature saying exactly
what I'm saying I'm indeed okay so what
am I doing here
I see cameras I see London I see France
s here under blue ooh
I gots good power I'm reloading ready to
go cocked locked and ready to drop I'm
asked blasts and ready to pass a brewski
all right
so what's the dealio flags captured do I
need to capture flags all right I'm
going for it nobody's gonna stop me huh
how risky no well this doesn't exactly
seem symmetrical maybe it's like a
pseudo symmetry going on here
flowertchi oh I thought that was a
capstone love it whoo flambe go where's
our goddamn flag what where's this what
is this nothing all right
interesting usually capture the flags
they have come some kind of for both
teams to be kind of even why would there
be a dead zone
I'm sorry pardon okay weird but I guess
we're just not gonna address that
anything even happened in the first
place it's gonna keep moseying on as if
everything is hunky and or dory
right that with the monitors on in here
just a little bit ago what do I go oh
hard down does this go
this is sorry okay I think I've got a
now that I've actually decided to look
there's a mini-map that has a little
blue icon in it so I can only imagine
that's where the blue flag is see some
maize I'm sorry what did you say to me
run that by me again oh that's not a
flag
ah has joined the server okay well I'm
gonna kick your ass at I'm gonna kick
your ad ass I'll kick your ass ass ass
hat your it is where you bet what Rick
was that hard why is that a thing that's
happening it's not gonna stop me from
getting the flag although the flag does
seem to be in a transient place which
definitely isn't conducive to normal
capture the flag rules you out that I'm
gonna your ass whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
I almost didn't see you kind of blended
into the environment a little bit
okay I don't like that unlike that at
all
Oh what weight but for a minute wait a
minute wait a hot second here
ding-dong I get it I'm the best there
ever was
none are better than me Oh L or I or the
line symbol they want to be my friend
ooh ah that's Morse code
this
maybe that was a mistake that might have
been a mistake that might have been him
hey whoa whoa whoa boys up my whole
master have your face what are you doing
what are you doing okay oh hello ah
they're saying hello hello all right
good good good good good good
who wants a face full of all learned no
definitely not I think it's down this
whoa I saw that I saw that some things
are trying to get me I saw something
oh hi what's down here dork
oh that little dorky ear okay
it's fine I got it I'm slow I'm slower
than it was four of three players online
well that's not possible at all that's
not even
for you who are you who are you huh who
are you
this shouldn't be yeah well you should
get good cuz I'm kicking your ass and
you losing bad so it is don't worry
about what could be it should exist oh
okay
read each second passing the curse is
growing stronger keep talking I'll blame
it on the controls like we all do blame
it on the curse to shoot twice if you
understand my words
come on firing you you I understand you
just fine buddy food
you understand me then wow you know as
much as one person can understand
another listen I'm listening there are
things humans can't understand people
end up vanishing use commands show me
meet me I'm on the map what am i what
wait what what what what just happen
what the frick just happened
what Oh what why what
it just booted me from the game but why
wait what the hell why oh come on I was
having fun you're gonna bug out on me
god damn it
of course I figure out a way to ruin
everything all right whatever let's
speed this speed time-lapse go
[Music]
I blazing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what was that oh this shouldn't be I
know this shouldn't be this shouldn't be
but it is buddy but it is okay so now
where are you did you reveal yourself on
the map to be over here somewhere
where are you friend where are you yeah
oh yeah damn
I understand now show me show me where
you are
whoa brick golf suck ass okay so that's
I think that's what game you oh forgot
me a game oh oh hey buddy hey how you
doing hello I'm here where are you
meeting you
I mean here if you could stop moving
around hello nice nose Yeah right
oh this is open before who got be cats
okay
Kabam yeah you I don't know what the
point of that is shooting the dolls but
whatever the access to server join join
the server what oh hi bud you don't look
so good um okay oh no not today but no
no stop stop don't do it again don't do
it again
stop
Oh No God are you kidding me
oh wait no I can get two other ones now
oh Claire - okay has joined oh my
there's no easy way out now well alright
then wait I don't know if you two given
me some better guidance from the get-go
maybe we wouldn't be in this situation I
can't explain to you what exactly is
going on oh so you don't know anything
so you're stupid I'm not allowed not in
this world you mean you don't have
privileges you need admin access or
something they give permission to very
few worlds out there this isn't one all
right then let's get this out of the way
who made this why they do it who they're
trying to bring back from the dead
they think they're whoa nope they think
the world should not exist yeah probably
died they want it gone why did they make
it why make it in the first place
and they want to use you ah all right
makes perfectly logical sense I am the
one after all
don't let them oh yeah of course makes
perfectly logical sense after all get
the flag but don't deliver it got the
flag get the flag buddy too good at this
game
destroy the jukebox I don't know if I
trust you but let's do it let's kill it
jukebox
they are coming from it
know about that find it and destroy it
fast I don't know where it is
how would I know where it is this is all
a whole bunch of nothing well
delivered was I not supposed to do that
hey whoa nice oh I'm guessing I wasn't
supposed to deliver it and that's a
prayer that's a bad thing that's bad
that's that's no good that's it's no
good I don't know what those words mean
but probably is not too good
whoo hey all right well that wasn't
ideal
what about Forrest what's in the forest
huh ooh oh there's a change of pace
he's pre-call let's go get the flag baby
this [ __ ] is mine
[ __ ] say nothing you joined the wrong
server did I go did I I don't know about
that
how'd you know I was on this server type
in Lobby please I don't think I want to
do that to be perfectly honest I don't
think I am oh wait are you there I think
I see you do not deliver the flags
please hi
hey I'm gonna deliver the flags will
deliver the beasts smarter than them mmm
I don't know how smart can one man be
holding on to this much genius is a
difficult task Bunte got it nailed it on
the best you got nothing to say about
this player - nothing at all he's gonna
let me do this without trying to
intervene in any way shape or form cuz
I'm gonna deliver these flags let's say
I make a serious effort to stop me here
I go
that's a lot of shadow people that's a
lot of sleep paralysis demons Oh scuse
me what's going on all right here we go
here we go boom I didn't what did I do
[Music]
[Music]
alright ok let's go back to Metro Oh God
jeez ohms Christmas criminy crawe god
damn it oh my god well I'm not gonna be
able to beat this game if you can't just
let me do anything alright there's gonna
be my leg my leg last attempted trying
to get into this like I said my time is
limited and I want to get want to get
all three of these deliciously
delectable horror games in I can't do it
if I have to wait around maybe I'm
supposed to go for the laughing because
there's this laughing that I hear maybe
if I find it I get to shut up the
jokester that's chuckling at me what am
i funny to you am i something to be
mocked just because I can't seem to get
to the end of this game doesn't mean
that you get to laughing what hi how are
you
what do you have a chicken or a bunny
what is what okay I guess we're going
this way then no oh hi Oh what
thank you um Oh
but what I do you joined the wrong
server I don't know if I did oh my boom
so the only thing I can think of is that
it at some point said that I could join
a specific lobby but I don't know what
the specific lobby was because I can't
remember it so I'm gonna go find it but
I go find it
hi I'm an idiot I literally just played
through to the end of the game and I
wasn't recording the entire time I was
not recording I don't know what happened
I don't know what happened I thought I
was recording I was recording why would
I press the record button again I swear
I just spent 30 minutes getting this
this is a person by the name of Jared
gaming I just found their video the
password is join 1 1 0-0 underscore X
space 3 1 tasting we're not right you
get sent to a special area Oh No oh
where are we so you get spent to his
Connor I've got guys I just I could show
you again but it took so long oh god I
don't have time this person Jared gaming
day have they figured out the mystery
and also I'll put the link in the
description below
it's so heartbreaking I don't know why I
don't know why I wasn't recording put a
link to this video here in the
description and the game is down there
too I I'm heartbroken i I just spent a
lot of time and it's all good to poop
guys I'm sorry I literally am out of
time guys please have mercy on me
I heart broken thank you everybody so
much for watching and they know if you
got other horror games that you want to
see in the comments below if you want to
see other scary games I've played I'll
link them in the description this has
just been the episode of unfinished
games thank you for watching if you
wanna see more they subscribe ring the
bell to be notified when I am putting up
videos leave a like if you somehow
enjoyed this video and thank you
everybody so much for watching but as
always I will see you
[Music]